i i think that's the other thing the
really positive thing that can happen is
you're seeing community
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
erica it's so good to see you what's up
what's up
how are you doing i'm doing really well
it's great
erica barstool is just such an iconic
to uh to the culture
such an iconic platform i did a bar
stool podcast yesterday
with adam lefko you know like i uh i'm
just so impressed
to watch what the organization has done
and i thought when they hired you
because we we got to jam
together in prior life that that was a
huge coup for them
and you've absolutely delivered on my
intuition to that question
how has barcelona pivoted during this
new world we live in how are how'd you
think about it
how did you absorb it were you like me
and completely
underestimated how long we would be in
you know in this
predicament you know how did it play out
for you and
the gang yeah awesome thanks for having
me gary i always love to see you um
and you know look bar still pivots all
the time i think we are a company
that is very present we're just present
so
coronavirus is present uh you know it's
a difficult time in the country
that's present you know our goal is to
make people laugh our goal is to make
content
our goal is to stick it to the big guys
and to be as disruptive
and innovative as possible we pivoted a
lot you know i think one of the
advantages
we had going into the quarantine is that
this is a company that was never spoiled
with much when i got to bar stool
there wasn't a single studio they didn't
have producers
there weren't a huge amount of resources
people had a computer
they had an iphone maybe they had a
microphone only very few of them did
and we kind of went back to what made
barstool
so great to begin with when dave portnoy
started it which is
it's a bunch of guys and girls who are
sharing their world
trying to be funny being very innovative
using
what's free and available from a
platform perspective to make content and
to give people an escape and
you know i think it's a big
responsibility i think people need an
escape right now i think there's a lot
that people want to escape from things
are very heavy
and for us you know we needed to pivot
back
from you know we now we have a lot of
resources we have a headquarters we have
all
types of studios we have all types of
it's a transition
i i'm sorry to interrupt you but i'm
sure a lot of entrepreneurs versus
executives are growing companies
i'd be lying if i didn't say hmm
would have been a hell of a lot more
easy and fun and
interesting to deal with coven when we
were 42 people
and one tiny office not a thousand
global but you know we we have an office
in singapore now that's doing extremely
well
and explode in the last 18 months they
got hit first so i was already dealing
with covid
before i was dealing with covet yep go
ahead yeah
and then you have to always pivot your
business you know you always
i i i you've got to have your head on a
swivel you know what i mean like that's
kind of how i think about like how are
you going to make money how are you
going to make content
how are you going to build partnerships
how do you how do you fix and focus on
what's happening right
speaking of that and i'm sorry to erupt
and in general i'm trying to be better
in
interrupting but in my podcast i have an
hour and these i have 15 minutes and i'm
trying to bring as much value to the
audience
you know restructuring when that happens
you know what can what can people learn
from the way you attack
that in the way you know because i'm
watching from afar i don't know all the
details
but i'm i'm dangerous and everything so
you know
what you know what what can they learn
from that you know i think
you have to be very i think people can
be delusional i think people spend a lot
of time
which is weird i think you're right no
no i think it's but it's honest i think
it's honest
uh people spend a lot of time looking
back
they wish things were the way they used
to be or they spend time looking down
which i think is looking at problems
and i think you have to look ahead and
in front of you you know so we
got small you know what i mean we
started focusing on
not multi-million dollar multi-year ad
deals or partnerships we started looking
what can we do today and what is
something that can run
right now um we've had our two biggest
months
in commerce ever in the history of
barstool and the reason is
we started to make content and we
realized we had to find a new way to
monetize it
that would be relevant right now so that
those are two examples on the business
side
talk to me about the app i'm hearing a
lot of buzz from the bar stool
characters about this app
you know it's getting a little hyped
here this morning
yeah the sports books coming so you know
it's a good example of
we've been busy the last three months
building
you know what we want to be the number
one sports betting brand
in the united states which will be bar
stool sports book we've partnered with
penn national
we've been hard at work with them in
terms of building the sportsbook
product both retail as well as from a
mobile perspective
we're spending a lot of time on the
marketing we're thinking about how do we
launch it how do we do
how do we do it the bar stool way which
will be different
more unconventional more unexpected more
ridiculous than anybody else and
i'm fired up about this category sports
betting is a huge area of growth in
sports
i think it's a huge area of growth of
opportunity from a revenue perspective
but i think it's going to be about trust
and loyalty and those are two things
that we have and take really seriously
yeah i think that's right and so what
what about
um what's your biggest observation as
just a human in your own buying behavior
or consumption behavior
during cobiner like just curious you the
gal like are you
buying what like what have you bought
dtc or direct to consumer that you'd
never bought before
and now you're like i'm never going to
the store to buy this anymore i like
this new product
this way you have anything like that i
you know what i think's changed is
i'm a massive online shopper like i i
bought a [ __ ]
out of air plants i love air plants i'm
not etsy buying air plants it's
ridiculous like it makes there's
zero point have an air plant um i have a
game with a guy who works for me where
we just text each other what we buy
um and you know he bought a yellow truck
and i'm buying air plants
um i think it was toyota so shout out
jack
but uh big shout out jack big shout out
for jack um
but you know what i would say has
changed is i think people are realizing
what they
need and what they don't need and part
of what drives
consumer behavior is want and
i think that's really changing i buy a
lot of clothes
i don't need to buy clothes anymore i'm
like this is
i don't i see the same frigging four
people every day like it's not
so so i think that that's changed i also
think people
want things that are special and limited
edition and mean something like that's
what i think is going to change is that
commoditized products or things that fit
in the middle
are what are going to get hurt the most
coming out of pandemics i think it's
true for colleges
i think it's true for a public plant by
the way
it this you know this is literally what
i wrote about my first book
that's what the internet does period
correct the internet
eats the middle
i think you just fully explained to me
why i'm spending literally
all of my money on sports cards i didn't
get into this with jack because i wanted
to
because i got to find some jack minor
league cards because i know they exist
but erica i'm telling you right now for
barstool you need
as the leader of the company you need to
get the whole organization to realize
what's going on with sports cards
i am watching a ton of sports betting
dna
yeah it's it's out of control it's
awesome
and it really it shows what people are
you know i think there's some really
good things that are going to come out
of the pandemic i think how people
think about their time their priorities
like
but nostalgia and collection are
two things that i think you were going
to see more it will create a reversal of
that
i i i will argue that when
all of us are much older watching
documentaries about the pandemic
there's going to be an incredible amount
of good that came from it
you know what what pandemic has done is
created stress
and what that stress has done is exposed
things and i think that we're all going
to go through a lot of pain whether that
is
macro social injustice whether that's
micro
hey wait a minute i don't think i like
my partner as much as i thought
we were just getting along because we
weren't around each other now that we're
in the same place for 120 days
you know that's obviously very painful
that's very painful but it's long-term a
good
thing yeah i mean there may not be a
person on earth
that more appreciates one step back two
steps forward
i'm obsessed with it and i think you
said something earlier i'm i'm obsessed
with as well which is delusion i think
this has caused
reflection and and i feel like that's
why there's so much
going on in the macro and the micro and
to your point
and i've always been hot on this if
you're you know you and jack have been
in my office
i am obsessed with nostalgia yeah i
believe i believe that it makes you feel
something like when i look at a 1990
frank thomas
leaf rookie card something weird happens
in my chemicals i go back to you know
it feels delicious and so i actually
you know ironically we haven't gotten to
talk about this so i'll just do it
publicly
i actually think to you you made a very
important point about bar stool
bar stool much by the way i associate
with barcelona because in a lot of ways
i feel like
i i as a human have this happening which
is there is some pushback to some of the
things that are done
but the when you triple click into
and you take it to the macro there's so
much right there's so much authentic
and the loyalty which gives permission
and i actually think barstool has the
permission to be one of the biggest
players in sports cards i actually think
it's going to be
a trillion dollar thing so i'm i'm
basically just pitching you on doing
more
sports card content because i want to
consume it so you can just throw your
old friend a bone
it would mean a lot to me all right good
all right final kind of
question or statement is there anything
that we haven't talked about you've got
i i saw something are you doing some
sort of running clip
maybe i'm getting this is there a
running club i started a running club
um i got this right right running club i
started a running club i saw it on
twitter
that's ridiculous i don't even like to
run um
but i think that what you're hitting on
is circumstance what people have had to
wake up to is what your circumstances
that's that's what the pandemic brought
on it
it created a heightened sense of
circumstance for me
it was like i don't have to commute i've
really stopped working out i
de-prioritize my wellness to do work
basically
every day of the week so i created this
thing where basically if you just run
two miles a day
like you just run two miles a day and
it's been awesome people do it like i do
it every day
so um i think that's the other thing the
really positive thing that can happen is
you're seeing community
and there are yeah there's a lot of
negatives happening there's a lot
a lot of things wrong with a lot of
people's circumstances
um but there's also real community and
support that you're finding on
on pretty micro based on a pretty micro
basis and that's that's what i've
created with the run club
i love that you know there's a lot of
innovators watching right now
like a lot of entrepreneurs or
corporates
that are really trying to change [ __ ]
you know
barstool you know controversial
you know energy based founder you know
uh growing back to what you said growing
into maturity
right how is it navigating the kind of
you know corporate business world you
know i gave jack a lot of daps earlier
which is like
you know when the reason that he got all
those daps to be very very
frank besides his deep humanity and
kindness is you can
once the blue moon find an executive who
actually sees it
and then is willing to try forget about
like you know
mission not accomplished as much at
toyota as i'd like or almost anywhere
else i do business with
you know how is it for you to navigate
that on the other side where
like i spend time when it has nothing to
do with vaynermedia
and people are like where should we
spend this money and my first meeting at
craft they're like we're going after
this guy i'm like you should spend on
barcelona like
i'm like this is why you [ __ ] lose
like you know like so if i'm doing that
like how are you navigating that with a
founder that you know
it's probably the same question i would
ask andrea you know like how do you deal
with a founder like this
you know like what are you dealing with
because i think it might help a lot of
people watching
yeah look like i love working with dave
portnoy i think dave portnoy
is one of the most genius gifted people
on the planet
now we get a lot of flack because the
cameras and microphones
and blog has been on for this company
for 16 years and these guys made a piece
of content every 30 minutes
so the minefield of [ __ ] people said
is enormous like it's just enormous
um but what i like about barstool is
that we are a place that is in
progression
and it is the true story of the
evolution
brands evolve people evolve we evolve
um and barstool has evolved in a massive
massive way now
you can either choose to your point
triple click into that or not
and that's you know what i've had you
you
i others that innovate can't control
that correct i cannot control
the good people at craft what i can say
is that if you are if you are ignorant
to what your consumer wants
and you are uninterested in
understanding the truth of something
then you're not the right partner for us
anyways
yeah and from afar it seems that the
industry has very much figured out
barstool in the last 24
months there's dramatically more you
know
acceptance and and they're winning with
it you know
what because we work i mean that's the
at the end of the day
like can we just actually i apologize i
don't i actually don't want you to say
anything else
okay honestly i swear andre i'm not sure
listen
jabari is a beast and i know we have
some other good i'm not sure i want to
do anything else
that literal statement just [ __ ] with
me so heavy
like there is such a disconnect in this
entire goddamn thing
of the small percentage that actually
worked
and the large percentage that
pontificate
yeah that's right yeah i love that eric
thank you so much for being on
you're welcome thanks for having me hey
everybody on youtube first of all thank
you so much so humbled for your time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out